so many people have had to you've had
great success but I'm sure a period of
time where you had to struggle in order
before you were in the business have odd
jobs that's the case for most actors
comedians did you have any particularly
bad jobs that you despised well yeah
yeah I had I had one in particular I
worked for a very famous fast-food chain
that will remain nameless and I actually
I did a bad thing so I was so bad at the
fries and burgers and all that that that
I'm Chucky fries Kentucky Fried Chicken
they don't do burgers Alemany i I was so
bad at the cooking and that I was
relegated to washing all the utensils
and then a colleague of mine had washed
the toilets with a brush and a bucket
and then left the bucket next to the
sink and I used the toilet brush to wash
all of the utensils
I know I know it's it's it's bad and and
I find and then when you realized your
mistake you cleaned them yes well what
actually happened is that the manager
came in looked at me look to the bucket
look to the brush and went and then
walked away and away because we can't we
can't discuss that that didn't happen
that didn't happen it didn't happen and
it didn't happen until tonight yeah
exactly is this restaurant it's just a
restaurant I would have eaten there
couldn't possibly say okay well I want
to know that I didn't eat there that I
didn't use what it was in London so okay
it's unlikely very fast yeah I haven't
done it since I moved to Hollywood
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]